من لبنان من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس
يعني كنت اتحدث انا و الزميل الياس
كرام عن عمليه يعني هناك كان يحدثنا عن
تضارب في الاهداف المرصوده لهذه العمليه
القضاء على حماس
نهائيا ام ازاله حماس ام ردع حماس ام
تنفيذ ضربه قويه لحماس ما كيف تابعت
التصريحات للمسؤولين الاسرائيليين بشان
الاهداف المعلنه لهذه
الحرب سلمى في اليوم الثاني او الثالث وضع
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو خارطه
الطريق خلال كلمه القاها احداها واهمها
القضاء على حركه حماس وبالتالي رد عليه
الناطق الرسمي ابو عبيده ايضا بخارطه
الطريق لحماس تقول بالدفاع عن القطاع
وبالتالي موضوع الرهائن هو ذات قيمه
استراتيجيه اليوم ما نشهده على الارض من
خلال القصف من خلال
اعلان افراغ شمال غزه بالذهاب 1.1 مليون
نسمه الى الجنوب وبالتالي هذا القصف
المركز وتوزيع القوى العسكريه
ل اسرائيل حول القطاع يعني هناك في الشمال
فرقه مدرعه في الشرق فرقتين مدرعتين
وبالتالي فرقه مظل وهذا القصف يدل على عده
امور معينه وعده سيناريوهات يعني الهدف
الاسرائيلي واحد ضرب حماس البنى التحتيه
القيادات ومن ثم نزع سلطتها عن القطاع هذا
اول هدف الثاني هدف حسب الاسرائيليين هو
تحرير الرهائن باقل عدد ممكن من القتلى
الاسرائيليين والمدنيين وهذا امر لا يحترم
اصلا يعني على موضوع المدنيين
وبالتالي الدخول الى قطاع غزه ونزع هذا
الهاجس الدائم المستدام عليها هل فعلا هو
قادر على ذلك يعني اجتياح بري شامل وكامل
لا يبدو لانه طلب اخلاء السكان الى الشمال
الى الجنوب هذا امر يعني ان الجنوب محيد
ولكن تقول بعض المعلومات انه بالاضافه الى
هذا القصف المركز على مدينه وقطاع غزه يدل
ان هناك احت مال ان يكون هناك خرق في وسط
غزه حيث المسافه تقارب 6 م بين الحدود مع
الفلسطين المحتله والبحر 6 كل بهدف
التطويق والانتقال الى مرحله لاحقه ولكن
اقول واعود يعني هذا الامر هل فعلا حضرت
حماس نفسها حسب ما راينا من خلال العمليه
التي نفذت في طوفان الاقصى انه وصلت الى
درجه متقدمه من الحفيه فهل فعلا جهزت
الداخل في غزه للقتال
المدني من بيت الى بيت ومن شارع الى شارع
وهنا الاسرائيلي سيدفع الثمن الغالي من
هنا قد يمكن القول هذا الدمار الشامل
والكامل لاهداف معينه يعني تقطيع المنطقه
حتى في قطاع غزه او حول مدينه غزه
وبالتالي فرض امر واقع ا فرض امر واقع و
يعني بموازاه ذلك هل ترى عميد الياس بانه
هناك يعني تبدو لك من خلال عمليات القصف
في محاور عده بان هناك حقيقه مثلا تقدر
تستطيع ان تسجلي منها خطه عسكريه
اسرائيليه لما قد تنفذه من عمليات بريه في
محاور عده كما
تتحدث انا اعتقد حسب الحشد وحسب يعني سلمى
دائما القطاع هناك ثلاثه ابعاد
الطوبوغرافيا
والجغرافيا والديموغرافيا يعني عندما
نتحدث عن الطوبوغرافيا تحدثنا عن وسط
القطاع عن الديموغرافيا الجزء الاساسي من
2.3 مليون نسمه هو في منطقه الشمال وهذا
امر يصعب العمليه العسكريه قد تكون في
منطقه الشمال يعني على معبر ارتس وما شابه
باتجاه عسقلان تكون هذه المنطقه منطقه
الضغط ومنطقه المسك وبالتالي ان تكون
العمليه المناوره هي من الوسط ومن المنطقه
الجنوبيه هذا هو المحتمل ولكن اقول اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن الانفاق نتحدث عن العبوات
الناسفه نتحدث عن القدره العسكريه للقتال
يعني
حروب
المدن تعطي المدافع توازن معين والريش كما
يقال دائما بحروب المدن قد يكون نقول عاده
المهاجم ثلاثه والمدافع واحد ولكن في حرب
المدن قد يصل الى واحد مقابل بالعشره فهل
استعدت حماس حسب ما راينا يجب ان تكون قد
حسبت لهذا السيناريو ولكن هناك فكره اخرى
تقول انه قد اسرائيل تقطع حتى مدينه غزه
وقطع غزه الى مناطق معينه وعزلها عن بعضها
اولا عبر القصف وبالتالي الدخول اليها
ولكن دائما نسال السؤال التالي سلمى المده
المعلنه المسموح فيها امريكيا المده لانه
القدوم الامريكي هو للسيطره على الوضع
واخذ الى مكان محدود وكالك ريسك كما يقال
المده المسموحه والكلف المنتظره من قبل
اسرائيل هناك من يطالب داخل اسرائيل انه
حتى لو كان هناك رهائن فلنضحك بهم من اجل
الانتهاء من غزه بالاضافه الى هذا الامر
في قاعده نيفاتيم وهي في النق في النقب
تبعد 50 م عن حدود غزه تم انزال العتاد
العسكري ريدي للاستعمال جاهز للاستعمال
بالاضافه الى
الطلب من القوات الدلتا الامريكيه في بعض
الدول الاوروبيه ان تكون جاهزه وهي خبيره
ب تحرير الرهائن او ما شابه ولكن هل سيكون
عملها استشاري انا اعتقد ان عملها استشاري
ا طيب عميد الياس يعني بدقيقه تقريبا ما
موقع الولايات المتحده واشنطن وبلينك كان
هناك البارحه في تل
ابيب اعتقد الاحتواء الامر وعدم فلت زمام
الامور لاسرائيل كي تقوم بما تريده اثنين
حمايه العمليه العسكريه من خلال ال حاملات
الطائرات وبالتالي توجيه رساله الى المحيط
وبالتالي ان تكون قد تكون عمليه غزه
ونتائجها تحضيرا لمرحله دبلوماسيه لاحقه
اها